bonsoir merci d'abord et toutes mes
félicitations à l'équipe de vie et sec
parce que je trouve qu'ils ont réussi
une première qui est tout à fait
impressionnante
donc je leur avais proposé comme titre
qui gouvernent internet et je suis
chercheur chercheur en sociologie et les
chercheurs ont souvent pour habitude d
détourner les questions même quand c'est
eux mêmes qui les ont posées et donc je
vais commencer par essayer de répondre à
une autre question qui est plutôt est ce
qu'il faut gouverner internet
est-ce qu'il faut trouver un modèle
politique pour internet et est ce qu'il
ya un modèle qui doit s'imposer alors la
question peut sembler un peu un peu
étrange mais en fait elle vient au moins
de l'origine de l'internet de ses
premiers libertariens américain mais
mais mais aussi européens mais français
comme louis pouzin et cetera célibert
ses libertés libertaire mais c'est pas
tout à fait la même chose qu'ils ont
imaginé un réseau qui n'aurait pas
besoin d'une autorité politique qui
pourrait s'autoréguler qui pourraient se
gouverner tout seul c'était une très
belle utopie qui s'est imposée et qui
continue à s'imposer un nombre d'acteurs
du réseau et puis il y avait des raisons
pratiques aussi qui faisait que après
tout une autorité politique imposer une
autorité politique à l'internet n'était
pas chose facile
il ya des problèmes évidemment de
mondialisation il ya des problèmes de
quelle est la bonne circonscrite quel
est le bourg la bonne la bonne
juridiction qui faisait que malgré tout
imposé des règles à l'échelon mondial
était difficile c'est pas absolument
impossible on a su faire dans des
espaces comme la mer on hâte qu'ils
n'appartenaient aussi à aucun n'est pas
aucun état pardon ou comme l'espace on a
parfaitement su faire une législation
internationale pour réguler mais sur
l'internet ça pose est quand même des
problèmes particulièrement compliqué
alors faut-il gouverner internet
la question pourrait presque vous
pourriez presque me dire mais
la question n'est-elle pas un peu
obsolète finalement à l'internet est
traversé par de très nombreuses règles
des trois îlots de très nombreuses
normes et il ya au moins trois pôles de
normalisation très important le premier
départ les états vous entendrez souvent
dire internet est ingouvernable
comme si les états l'europe les états
nationaux ne pouvait rien imposer sur
internet
et bien ça c'est une c'est une lieu
commun est une idée fausse internet est
traversée et obéit aux règles des états
par exemple en matière de racisme on a
vu avec la feria où il ya très longtemps
que l'état français a pu poursuivre avec
une ruse pour suivre un site qui héberge
et de la propagande nazie
on sait pour suivre les sites qui font
du racisme alors bien sûr vous me direz
c'est pas parce qu'il ya des
législations que ça empêche les gens de
produire des propos racistes pédophiles
et aidera patin couffin
peu importe la loi n'a jamais empêché
les criminels de tuer les voleurs de
volée mais la loi est là pour dire la
norme pour dire la règle et l'état les
états nous disent déjà d'énormes sur
internet il ya un deuxième
l'état aussi a pu faire mieux
l'état a même enfin les états ont même
inventé des notions générales qui arrive
à réguler certains aspects de la vie sur
internet par exemple le droit des
hébergeurs le fait que un hébergeur
n'est pas responsable de tous les
contenus qui sont sur son site ce qui
empêcherait qui feraient fermer dès
demain la majorité des hébergeurs
puisqu'on sait bien que personne ne peut
contrôler ce qui se passe sur internet
le droit d hébergeur a pu aussi
s'imposer à l'échelon international
et alors ça c'était premier groupe
d'acteurs les états
le deuxième groupe d'acteurs beau enfin
extrêmement puissant qui chaque jour
nous imposent leurs règles
ce sont les supras acteurs de l'internet
et vous les connaissez tous vous êtes
tous les jours en contact
enfin j'imagine comme moi avec eux ce
sont les
google facebook twitter etc toutes ces
énormes société dont la capitalisation
boursière est bien supérieur à la valeur
alors leur chiffre d'affaires il
n'empêche ce sont ces sociétés à travers
leur contrat et je fais l'hypothèse que
comme moi vous n'êtes jamais allé lire
les contrats qui pourtant réguler tous
les jours votre comportement sur ces
plateformes sese seko méga société c'est
supra acteurs nous impose en permanence
un certain nombre de façons de faire de
vivre ensemble de nous comporter
d'acheter et c'est alors l'état qui par
est échappé aux législations nationales
par exemple en matière d'imposition
commence a quand même rencontré en face
d'elle des états qui ne se laisse plus
complètement faire ça a été par exemple
de l'italie dont on pense pas tout pour
que l'état soit très puissant mais elle
a une autorité de la concurrence qui est
allé dire à google ça va bien votre
affaire de gestion des revenus publicité
s'est fait dans une opacité totale
donc ça c'est pas possible la
répartition dame incertain on va doit
être rendu explicite elle a dû plier
donc google a plié en italie google a
accepté de rendre public et clé de
répartition de la manne publicitaire et
comme google a très vite compris que ce
qui s'imposait en italie allé s'imposer
dans les autres pays ils ont cédé à
l'échelon européen sur cette question là
donc c'est une toute petite avancée et
on voit déjà d'acteurs de l'internet
peut trouver en face de lui des
principes supérieurs auxquels ils sont
obligés de se plier
et puis il ya le troisième pôle le
troisième pôle qui est probablement le
plus pratique le plus imaginatif encore
que les supras acteurs ont beau bien sûr
et beaucoup de compétences en innovation
mais le troisième est moins dans des
voies préinscrits témoin près préempté
par le commerce c'est tous les acteurs
de l'internet ce sont les 1
internautes d'abord mais plutôt encore
les internautes très actifs et
internautes intéressés
les internautes qui ces collectifs
formelles ou informelles qui ont su
fabriquer la normalisation d'internet
qu'ils savent être créé des collectifs
qui saf animer les communautés et on a
vu juste avant moi
goody de ce collectif qui essaie
d'utiliser le réseau et les capacités
capitaliste du réseau al'avantage une
cause qui dépasse le qui le dépasse
largement
donc j'aurais pu vous citer aussi de du
w3c
ce collectif d'acteurs qui a fabriqué
les normes de ce qui est aujourd'hui
l'internet
donc en gros ce que je vous dis c'est
que oui il ya bien des régulations dans
le réseau c'est pas vrai que le réseau
d'eau be et complètement dans les dans
un état d'anarchie totale
mais aujourd'hui on a une une régulation
qui est opaque qui est éclatée qui est
incertaine tout on ne vit pas si mal sur
le réseau et pourquoi essayer de le il
ya un certain nombre d'effets pervers à
l'absence de d'explicitation sur ses
formes de régulation
je voudrais juste en évoquer deux la
première c'est sur le piratage alors
bien sûr aucun d'entre nous n'a jamais
piraté un morceau de musique ou un film
mais à l'extérieur de cette salle il y
en a beaucoup qui font autrement et les
acteurs les ce qu'on appelle les ayants
droit c'est à dire par exemple les
maisons disque les artistes musiciens
nous disent attention vous êtes
responsable les pirates sont
responsables de lâcher par exemple de la
mort de l'industrie du disque en europe
mort toute relative
en fait il ya quinze ans que mes
collègues économistes
nos collègues économistes travaillent
sur cette question de l'impact du
piratage sur l'industrie du disque et
sur le domaine de la musique et ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'ils sont en réunion ils
n'ont jamais réussi à se mettre d'accord
sur le fait qu'il y avait un rapport
c'est à dire personne n'a réussi à
prouver et ya même des gens qui disent
le contraire que le piratage nuit à la
musique il ya des économistes très
réputé qui ont montré qu'au contraire
les pirates étaient ceux qui achetaient
le plus donc au contraire le piratage
mais bon ils sont pas tous d'accord
ils sont tout accès à certains ça
d'accord mais en revanche il ya quelque
chose sur lequel tout le monde est
d'accord c'est c'est l'impact du
piratage sur l'allongement des droits de
propriété et ça c'est grave parce que ça
veut dire
l'allongement des droits de propriété
n'a cessé de s'allonger depuis que bon
marché les a créés et aimant failli à
deux siècles et demi mais là dans les
dernières années on ne cesse d'étendre
la durée de protection des oeuvres qu'un
artiste vivre de son travail on en verra
un tout à l'heure c'est une très bonne
chose et c'est tout à fait normal que 75
ans après sa mort ses enfants ses
petits-enfants ses
arrière-petits-enfants enfin avec ce que
nous a été dit je ne sais pas combien de
générations continuent à vivre sur son
travail
là c'est un déni de ce qui a fait la
spécificité de notre culture notre
culture il y avait un domaine public
c'est à dire qu'il y avait un moment on
vivait de son oeuvre
mais après la culture qui est un bien
collectif qui est quelque chose que les
gens construisent quand même à partir de
tout leur environnement à partir de ce
qu'ils ont appris à l'école à partir de
ce qu'ils ont lu à partir la culture
c'est pas que dans la tête des gens
c'est vraiment ce qui vient les nourrir
de partout et donc si cette culture tout
d'un coup elle devient privatiser c'est
une mauvaise chose pour notre avenir et
ce qui est sûr est que le piratage a
entraîné un durcissement considérable
aux états unis mais même en europe
un durcissement considérable de la
protection de la propriété
intellectuelle
donc ça ses premiers effets pervers le
deuxième je vais aller beaucoup plus
vite parce que tout le monde on entend
parler tous les jours
c'est l'impact de enfin c'est la
surveillance le contrôle la cense voir
la censure qui est exercée en permanence
par les états les états non
démocratiques comme la chine bien
entendu mais aussi les états
démocratiques comme les états unis et on
voit bien que l'absence de règlement est
de régulation l'absence de politique
générale a permis par exemple aux états
unis de surveiller la planète entière
alors bon que faire c'est vraiment la
question qui nous est maintenant
adresser comment comment agir face à
cette situation
eh bien ma proposition c'est de vous
dire bah nous sommes en 1788
nous sommes dans une période pré
révolutionnaire et les période
prérévolutionnaire ça se prépare déjà
depuis un certain temps donc ça s'est
préparé depuis longtemps mais il va
falloir passer aux actes il faut
inventer quelque chose d'autre
la démocratie représentative sur
internet ça marche pas parce que si vous
mettez si vous faites voter pour un
gouvernement de l'internet
les chinois pour nous envoyer un
parlement qui sera tout sauf
démocratique créatif et ouvert enfin les
chinois dans tous les cas lors leurs
gouvernements mais on peut on peut être
on peut compter sur sur eux non il nous
faut inventer la constitution de lampes
à la constitution de l'an il faut nous
faut inventer les constitutions de
l'internet parce qu'il ya pas qu un seul
internet
il ya une pluralité il ya une multitude
et à une multiplicité de d'internet qui
sont faits en fonction de la façon dont
on les utilise de ce qu'on met dedans
des applications qu'on utilise etc etc 7
c'est cette multiplicité de constitution
qui va falloir auquel il va falloir que
nous pensions et et ça il ya des gens
qui ont déjà commencé qui ont déjà
commencé à le faire
des internautes intéressés comme les
acteurs du libre
les producteurs d'application les grands
animateurs de communautés
ils ont commencé à poser un certain
nombre de principes qui vont qui vont
nous être utile par exemple des
principes comme le raf consensus c'est
l'idée que on va prendre des décisions
non pas à la majorité qui a quand même
des effets pervers en l'occurrence n'ont
pas la majorité mais en se mettant
progressivement d'accord sur des
contenus on voit aussi des formes de
régulation
ils sont très intéressantes comme les
régulations de wikipédia le savoir
collectif qui est maintenant quand même
que tous les jours nous consultons tous
tous ensemble même si on lui trouve des
limites
on a vu émerger des choses par exemple
pour repenser la propriété
intellectuelle en permettant le partage
c'est les systèmes de creative commons
donc en gros nous avons les principes de
base la transparence
et puis la neutralité du réseau
c'est pas celui qui paye le plus qui
empêche ceux qui payent le moins d'aller
sur le réseau et d'envoyer des contenus
donc nous avons les principes de base
nous avons des pistes pour ouvrir vers
de nouvelles normes de nouvelles règles
de nouvelles faces une nouvelle
politique une nouvelle cité commune
donc c'est maintenant à nous et à vous
d'inventer cette nouvelle civic site et
de l'internet